[Music]
this is arguably the most popular place
to come if you want your hair back
istanbul's hair transplant industry is
worth north of a billion us dollars and
it's estimated over 200 000 people a
year come here in the hope of regaining
their hair
but it's a lightly regulated industry no
one knows exactly how many clinics are
out there or how many operations take
place
sadly i have no idea and i've been
looking at this for over a decade
um it is a data black hole i i need a
calculator to tell you a number actually
we are assuming
about
1500 2000 operations
are made
daily basis in turkey
the industry has exploded in size over
the last decade attracting patients from
across the world
in this situation you really need a lot
of attention
but as more men pack their bags and fly
to turkey are medical standards being
dropped in favor of profit
a hair transplant surge in many ways has
become a market so people see hair
transplant surgery as a commodity the
business of hair transplantation has
been very much designed on bums on seats
and telling people what they want to
hear and sadly this is a this is surgery
and in the wrong hands it can be
devastating
[Music]
have traveled from the usa to istanbul
to radically change the way they look
how do you feel it's good
they're here at blue magic a premium
hair treatment clinic in istanbul
i started losing my hair about five
years ago
it was very upsetting very when it
started the shed basically and uh it's
like every day in the morning when you
wash up you see it more here in the sink
and you're thinking yourself like what's
going on what can i do different
hussein's 55 from detroit michigan his
friends from scottsdale arizona
yeah most of them they seem to be black
they discovered blue magic online
and i actually looked away from your
site to other people that did their own
videos so that gave me a good feeling
about it they said that they got a lot
of attention that gave me a good feeling
about it
so what do we do actually we're
extracting this one because it's
equality good to hear
like most patients in istanbul hussein
and sard have undergone a procedure
called follicular unit excision or fue
this is where clumps of hair follicles
are removed from the sides and back of
your head and implanted into the areas
where the hair loss is
it takes about four to five hours and if
it's done correctly it looks natural
having my hair back will probably make
me feel better than i have in a long
time
it's been it's been a long time since i
felt this way just having it would be
great
with their luxury offices and clinics
blue magic are at the expensive end of
the spectrum but even with the hotel and
translator included clients can expect
to spend around four to five thousand us
dollars for the treatment
that's typically half the price you'd
pay in the usa uk or eu
you look like a buckethead
hussain inside are heading back to the
state's happy customers hoping that
their days of hat wearing are behind
them thanks guys
[Music]
exactly how large istanbul's hair clinic
industry is is impossible to pin down
although the turkish ministry of health
sets standards for the industry which
are in line with eu regulations clinics
are not required to say how many
procedures take place and medical
associations are voluntary
so i think it's difficult because there
aren't any official numbers
there are
clinics that perhaps have multiple
websites
perhaps named differently but actually
are just one organization
dr greg williams is a practitioner and
president of the british association of
hair restoration surgery
people see her transplant surgery as a
commodity that they can shop around for
the cheapest price but i think the issue
is that hair transplant surgery can be
um
shall i say bought so much cheaper in
some of the the health tourism
destinations that are uh marketed to
the male public
i think my colleagues in turkey have a
better feel and i hear from them but but
even they i don't think have have a full
grasp on the magnitude of the hair
transplant surgery industry in turkey
if getting exact numbers is hard finding
clinics is easy you only need to type
istanbul hair treatment into instagram
and you're down the rabbit hole
i think it's fair to say that there are
some clinics that are spending thousands
if not hundreds of thousands of pounds
on their social media marketing
and and the problem is that young guys
who have hair loss are just quite often
so devastated and so desperate and
just needed and i get that so often
once you click on any form of advert or
any form of product or any form of
service they
are cleverly kind of
heavily weighted the adverts that come
through and that kind of resonates with
that hair loss sufferer and
is there as a constant reminder that
there are solutions out there and that
you need to take a step forward with
this
the pressure of social media is
something spencer stevenson knows well
he hosts a podcast called the ball truth
uk and speaks with men who've jumped on
a plane to get surgery and then
regretted it
sadly there are a number of
clinics that don't necessarily perform
surgery in the best interest of the
patient i see here in the uk a high
number of repair patients i was a repair
patient all this is hair transplanted
hair just come from the back and then
move to the front
spencer's had 13 hair transplant
operations many to repair the poor work
done when he was younger
the first procedure that i had done was
relatively small but it was done with a
strip via the strip procedure and it
ended up being mini and micro grafts in
the hairline so it looked like
a hair transplant it didn't look like a
natural head of hair which then
meant that i had to continue to find a
way to resolve that and make it much
more natural
finally i see a great deal that people
have an immediate reaction they see an
advert they see an affordable price and
they're so desperate and they are so
vulnerable that they feel that it's a
solution to all their problems and that
it can be fixed very quickly and they
are on a flight out of here
choosing the right clinic in istanbul's
crowded and social media savvy market
isn't easy
there's many clinics which offer surgery
for less than two thousand dollars with
little to no medical oversight when the
doctor will give us the confirmation
that everything is fine
hazim atel runs blue magic's medical
teams and he argues only a fraction of
the city's clinics prioritize medical
care over profit
350 clinics
i can tell
maybe 10 of them they do this job in
medical way they focus on the medical
side and the rest
it's a business it's a job it's a work
okay
because
there are some clinics some clinics they
were making daily up to 50 operation
daily okay
[Music]
this conveyor belt approach relies on
one of the most controversial elements
of the hair transplant sector the use of
technicians
in turkey as in the us and the uk
technicians are often used to assist the
procedure but it's the extent of their
use which makes the difference
when you cut into the skin i would
suggest that surgery
and that should be done by a doctor
who is part of a who is has a governing
body to whom they are responsible to
keep their license
and in uh in a lot of health tourism
destinations that's not what happens
that step is delegated
to
non-doctors now a lot of
[Music]
doctors in these clinics will justify
that by saying well these non-doctors
are trained they're technicians they're
very good at the job a lot of doctors
will say the technicians are better than
they themselves the doctor that does not
make it right that does not make it
ethical and in some countries that does
not make it legal
the technician model is one of the
biggest factors in helping to drive down
the price of surgery a doctor oversees
the work a technician does it
if you are requiring this like you want
a doctor to do it from a to z this will
cost you a lot of money because you are
requesting a private doctor to be from a
to z with you so the cost of course will
be too much high
so that's why technicians are needed
technicians these days with the
experience they are having they are
reaching an amazing they are doing an
amazing work actually
operating room is
uh
ready for tomorrow's patient
doctor cayenne cyanuglue is one of three
fellows of the international society of
hair restoration surgery in istanbul
he like everyone else uses technicians
but he does the incisions and
extractions himself
it is
a competition between this kind of
technician clinics
and
this kind of
companies
uh
yeah
they may compete
i don't think there's a big competition
between doctors there's a competition
between technician clinics
dr cyanuglu like the other clinics we've
spoken to believes it's time the sector
was regulated but he's got concerns
when you
put big restrictions
and regulations
they
i mean the sector will go a illegal way
so
it is not easy to regulate but it has to
be regulated because it's uh about life
i mean you are
doing a procedure on human
the most at-risk group a young men who
rush to get the operation done by
clinics who are only too happy to take
their business
and
when they have their transplant quite
often it will be
done to a design that they've requested
which is low youthful rounded squared
off temples and it may look good for a
couple years but when they reach 30 40
50 60 and they've lost a lot more hair
that's they're going to be their
permanent hairline because those hairs
don't deteriorate when they're taken
from the sides in the back of the head
and transplanted they're there for the
duration now what i do think is going to
happen in
5 10 15 20 years time is i think we're
going to see an absolute epidemic
of men who had
aggressive hair lines transplanted when
they were young by aggressive i mean low
and quite rounded
and then go on to lose significant
amounts of hairs to start to look like
they're balding fathers and grandfathers
which is what they wanted to avoid
happening by having a transplant without
realizing that the transplant's not
going to stop that happening from a from
a man point of view when you start to
lose your hair you are very isolated and
it is very easy to become very consumed
by hair loss and seeking a resolve for
that and because of the nature of the
internet and the nature of social media
the
the information is a plenty out there
but the accurate information isn't
aplenty and we need to make sure that
people find those resources to get the
right decisions made the messages are
do your homework do your research
just don't
make rash decisions
and
if you are a proper
candidate for hair transplant i
recommend hair transplant to everyone
but everybody who look for a solution
for hair loss has to
do their homework very well and you they
have to find the right doctor and rise
right place everywhere
[Music]
on the next episode of business of
beauty
china's aesthetic medicine industry is
booming and the country's youth is
driving the trend
the arrival of dedicated cosmetic apps
have made booking surgery as simple as
ordering a takeout
now the market in china is worth over 30
billion dollars making up for 17
of the global industry
but the days of paying for perfection
might be numbered as the chinese
government looks to crack down on an
industry that they claim is distorting
aesthetic perceptions
[Music]
[Music]
you